Do you think you people
can separate physics from maths? Can yes sir? Yes sir. Come on,
who is the Baahubali of the class and who is
Bhallaldev? Come here immediately, here is the physics,
here is the maths, okay, what has to be done,
this is right.  Physics and matches are done, now come,
who is Bahubali, where is Bahubali Balal Dev, come
here, now tell me with all your might, as much as possible, as much as possible, as much as possible, it did not happen,
why did it not happen, why did it not happen? Hey
brother, that's it, that's it, that's it, how much did you find?
No, now why is it not separated, let
me tell you, look at all the
pages that you guys have created in connection,
a normal reaction force is being applied on every page.
Okay, if a normal reaction force
is being applied on every page, then the value of overall normal is  It became too
much and because the overall normal became
so much, then the limit increased, then the
external force that you are applying is
not able to apply more than the limit and
hence the object is not moving, so that is why I say that in
mathematics.  It
cannot be studied without Physics, hence it is
necessary to study Maths, only then Physics will be understood properly.